[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la soirée de gala qui a réuni à l'Opéra
monsieur Lopez Matteo c'est son épouse
et le président de la République
française et Madame De Gaulle au milieu
des plus hautes personnalités de l'État
a marqué la fin de la visite à Paris du
président du Mexique une visite dont le
général de Gaulle a pu dire qu'elle
était un événement solennel c'est la
première fois depuis quatre siècles que
la France reçoit le chef de l'État du
Mexique
[Musique]
chômeur ont assiégé le Parlement de
Londres en réclamant du travail effet
brutal de la crise économique dont
souffre la Grande-Bretagne avec ses
700100 travail
Manon tu beaucoup de mal à contenir les
manifestants il n'y parving au prix
d'une lutte sévère
bilan de la journée 10 policiers blessés
et des dizaines d'arrestations
[Musique]
en Pologne où le froid s'accroche on
chasse l'hiver à la grenade
pour accélérer la débâcle de la Vistule
les grands moyens ont été utilisés pour
réduire en miettes ce miroir de 50 cm
d'épaisseur
la glace est rompue mais la marche
tumultueuse de cette interminable sorbet
a été fatal aux vieux pont de bois de
d'Evelyne dont l'une des arches a été
emportée
dernier méfait d'un long hiver qui se
venge ainsi de ce coup de pouce
artificiel donné au printemps
lorsque vous sortez d'une banque avec à
la main une sacoche apparemment rebondi
un bon conseil n'oubliez pas que la
rubrique des faits divers est pleine de
récits de hold-up tous plus audacieux
les uns que les autres filez droit votre
chemin et surtout ne regardez pas en
l'air
[Musique]
cartel est la toute dernière technique
demandant peu de moyens et le minimum
d'investissement que deux jeunes voyous
viennent d'employer en plein Paris à
éviter cependant un premier avril
[Musique]
nos deux énergumènent auraient tout de
même dû y regarder de plus près ils ont
peut-être fait d'un clochard le gagnant
d'un des quelques 65000 lots de la
tranche spéciale de Pâques de la Loterie
Nationale et peut-être du gros lot d'un
million il se passe des choses tellement
curieuses le premier avril
est-ce que encore un prince héritier à
marié dans un royaume lointain il est
vrai au confins de l'un et de la Chine
ces choses faites le maharaja du Sikim a
uni son fils à Miss hobkok ce qui value
au haut de forme de l'Oncle Sam
d'apporter une note pittoresque dans une
vieille cérémonie bouddhiste
[Applaudissements]
dans une pagode richement décorée Miss
pop Cook après avoir absorbé selon la
tradition le thé au beurre de buffle a
reçu des mains de ses nouveaux sujets
des écharpes de soi blanc
[Musique]
c'est ainsi qu'une charmante
représentante de la société new yorkaise
est devenue princesse du Sikkim
[Musique]
monsieur Marc Jacquet ministre des
Travaux publics et des transports a
officiellement ouvert le nouveau tronçon
de l'autoroute du Sud qui ajoutera 9 km
de béton au 36 déjà en service
[Musique]
une petite consolation pour les
automobilistes que les fêtes de Pâques
lancent traditionnellement sur les
routes et qui en a un endroit de France
doivent compter cette année avec les
méfaits du dégel
Fontainebleau c'est encore un peu
rapproché de Paris c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour les beaux jours
[Musique]
en Angleterre on n'avait rien trouvé
jusqu'à présent pour empêcher les
tracteurs de s'embourber dans la terre
grasse au grand désespoir semble-t-il
des fermiers britanniques qu'ils se
consolent l'un vers kraft vient de
régler leurs problèmes d'une manière
radicale en supprimant purement et
simplement les roues la machine agricole
de demain glissera sur un coussinet
d'air et dire que des siècles durant
l'inventeur anonyme de la roue fut
considéré comme un génie
[Musique]
épine dorsale du Pérou la Cordillère des
Andes domine une vaste région ou vivent
entre 3000 et 5000 mètres les deux tiers
de la population péruvienne il était
donc nécessaire que la route moderne
franchisse cette gigantesque barrière et
que le train lui-même s'y aventure à une
altitude supérieure à celle du Mont
Blanc
centre actif de ces routes terre du
Pérou Puno est aussi le port le plus
haut du monde à 3800 mètres d'altitude
au bord du lac Titicaca ce port assure
le transit vers la Bolivie des
marchandises venus de la côte du
Pacifique c'est aussi un pôle
d'attraction pour les riverains à
l'heure de l'embarquement on y voit
fleurir les chapeaux melons et les
chapeaux mous auxquels certaines
indiennes pourtant continuent de
préférer le chapeau plat du folklore
12 fois la superficie du lac de Genève
le lac Titicaca a de tout un favoriser
l'élevage et les deux y côtoient sur ses
rives les troupeaux de Lama animaux
domestiques à tout faire du Pérou
quant aux pêcheur ils sont restés
fidèles à leur barque ancestrales qu'il
fabrique eux-mêmes avec les roseaux du
lac
avec ses étonnantes embarcations il
pêche des truites géantes certaines
mesures jusqu'à un mètre 30
étrange pays où il semble tout à coup
que le temps se soit arrêté en 1911 on
découvrait au sommet d'une montagne les
ruines d'une ville Machu Picchu déjà
abandonné du temps des Incas et vieille
peut-être de 6000 ans on y retrouve un
observatoire du soleil sur lequel les
archéologues continuent de s'interroger
et une immense pierre où était sacrifiée
des victimes humaines au dieu du soleil
plus proche de nous le souvenir des
Incas par contre est resté vivant les
mines d'où il faisait extraire l'or et
l'argent fabuleux sont encore en
exploitation
offlant des montagnes sur les mêmes
terrasses qu'il firent bâtir il y a des
siècles se perpétuent aujourd'hui les
mêmes cultures étagées
les méthodes agraires sont restées
identiques même organisation collective
et pour cultiver la pomme de terre dont
ils sont les vrais inventeurs toujours
la même arrêt de bois
ancienne capitale de l'empire Inca Kuzco
est elle-même aujourd'hui la synthèse de
deux civilisations chaque maison en
témoigne sur un rez-de-chaussée un cas
aux pierres imbriquées pour résister au
tremblement de terre les conquérants ont
tout naturellement élevé un premier
étage à l'espagnol
[Musique]
et dans les scènes de la rue le prêtre
apparaît comme le conseiller écouté au
milieu des descendants du peuple inca
converti au catholicisme les Indiens de
la montagne ont gardé dans l'expression
de leur nouvelle foi le même respect
craintif que leurs ancêtres
manifestaient à l'égard du dieu du
soleil
symbole même de la double hérédité de
Cusco le Christ monumental domine les
restes gigantesques de la forteresse de
saxa waman qui fut le théâtre de la
dernière bataille des Incas et des
conquistadors mais si l'on sait qu'au
pied de ce trône les troupes défilaient
voici cinq siècles devant l'empereur du
soleil on ne sait toujours pas comment
purent être amenés et dressés ces blocs
pesant plusieurs dizaines de tonnes ici
le présent partout se mélange au passé
et à ces mystères
[Musique]
prélude à une semaine diplomatique qui
semble amorcer un nouveau démarrage des
relations France États-Unis la remise de
la médaille d'or et du célèbre calot de
l'American Legion à Monsieur George
Pompidou le Premier ministre avec ses
remerciements a évoqué l'alliance au
sein de laquelle la France et les
États-Unis sont indissolublement liés
pour la défense de la liberté
[Applaudissements]
16000 israéliens de 15 à 85 ans
participent à la traditionnelle marge de
4 jours à travers le décor sauvage des
montagnes de Judée
un marathon de 140 km pour les adultes
civils et militaires limité à deux jours
et 65 km pour les jeunes et les vétérans
[Musique]
au soir du 4e jour ils ont fait d'un
Jérusalem une entrée triomphale le
défilé à travers les rues de la ville
sainte n'a pas duré moins de trois
heures
[Musique]
plusieurs groupes venus d'Europe et
d'Afrique c'était joints à ce
gigantesque rally qui a lieu chaque
année à la veille des fêtes de Pâques
[Applaudissements]
dans les régions minières l'accord
conclut entre les syndicats et la
direction des huyères a été généralement
bien accueilli sauf à Lens ou quelques
réactions se sont manifestées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si on sent le lendemain et dans
l'ensemble des bassins les mineurs ont
repris le chemin de la mine
[Musique]
le plus grave des conflits sociaux du
moment a été résolu dans les autres
parties du secteur public les
négociations avec les syndicats ont été
menées également à bonne fin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en Indonésie les ruption brutale du Mont
Agong révérée à l'égal d'un dieu a semé
la mort et la désolation dans la partie
nord-est de l'île de Bali dans le nom
évoque pourtant davantage le paradis que
l'EN fait au pied du volcan 5 villages
ont été rasés par les coulées de lave
plutôt que de s'enfuir les habitants
avaient préféré rester sur place et
tenté par des prières d'apaiser la
colère du dieu aussi les morts et les
blessés se comptent-ils par milliers les
soins sont donnés sur place avec des
moyens de fortune le mont a Gong était
assoupi depuis plus d'un siècle et les
prières ne semblent toujours pas apaiser
le volcan
[Musique]
Hong Kong connaît actuellement une
période de sécheresse intense depuis 6
mois pas un nuage pas une goutte d'eau
aussi pour attirer l'attention divine
sur la situation désespérée du Paysana
local des prières ont-elles été dites
dans les temples bouddhistes de la
colonne
[Musique]
et de plus 500 oiseaux ont été l'objet
d'un rite spécial après avoir été
aspergé d'eau bénite au cours d'une
cérémonie solennelle dans le plus grand
temple de Hong Kong ils ont été remis en
liberté c'est gentils messagers ont pour
mission d'intercéder en faveur des
humains auprès du génie des quatre
saisons
[Musique]
a été dessinateur
jamais pu garder une place
celui-ci notaire s'est enfui ne pouvant
plus supporter sa belle-mère cet autre
professeur a été abandonné par sa femme
et son chien
quel que soit leur raison ils sont ainsi
peut-être 20 000 déclassés dans la
région parisienne réputée irrécupérables
en un mot des clochards
pourtant pour Freder la gamberge dont
toute la famille avait péri à Oradour il
s'est produit un événement singulier une
voiture la déposée devant un château du
Berry au tourelles renaissant on l'a
conduit à travers les couloirs vers une
chambre une vraie chambre avec un vrai
lit où il s'est installé lui son quignon
de pince à boîte de conserve et tout son
trésor il avait accepté de vivre
l'expérience teintée au château
doublesse
ou blesse depuis 10 ans Jean-François
Perrette si est donné pour but d'essayer
de rendre à la vie sociale les vagabonds
irréductibles les inadaptés de notre
temps
là ils reprennent l'habitude de
l'activité avec le gîte et le couvert
assuré et surtout ils peuvent retrouver
le goût de vivre en société
mais tous n'y parviennent pas rien n'est
plus difficile parrait-il que de
s'arracher à la cloche et le soir
quelquefois les souvenirs remontent
les souvenirs du petit matin plasmobert
à l'heure où Simon Le Bourgeois coco la
baratte loulou les additions judo sans
un fond le compte de leur butin pour
l'offrir sur les quais aux acheteurs
car ils ont des acheteurs des
chiffonniers et même des antiquaires
[Musique]
au bout du compte quelques centimes ou
quelques francs
il y a aussi le rendez-vous quotidien
devant chez Roger la grenouille l'une
des adresses de Paris où ils savent
trouver une soupe gratuite
en longue file ils attendent
ici le silence règne personne ne parle à
personne
une fille indienne de solitude
additionnelles
[Musique]
un timide sourire de remerciements et
l'on va consommer sur le trottoir
[Musique]
dormir manger et boire sont les seuls
grands soucis des clochards et arracher
ses hommes à l'emprise d'un tel univers
est une entreprise difficile c'est la
mission que c'est fixé l'association
doublesse si elle ne compte pas que des
réussites du moins avec elle l'espoir
subsiste
[Musique]
à 7000 km de Paris Pointe-à-Pitre la
ville la plus importante de la
Guadeloupe offre le spectacle d'une cité
en pleine transformation
[Musique]
si le marché a gardé son parfum
d'autrefois les antiques cases de bois
par contre semblent avoir la boucheotte
l'une après l'autre en effet au pas
nonchalant des beux elles abandonnent
leur quartier d'origine
c'est que les deux départements des
Antilles françaises sont en train de
changer de visage
[Musique]
avec ces immeubles tout neufs
Pointe-à-Pitre se place à la tête de ce
mouvement général d'expansion
[Musique]
mais cette France du bout du monde a
conservé tout son charme provincial
[Musique]
Martinique aux trois il est on continue
d'entretenir le souvenir de celle qu'on
baptisa voici quelques 200 ans dans
cette petite église et qui devait
devenir l'Impératrice des Français
sur l'ancien domaine familial de
Joséphine de Beauharnais les jolis
métisses se font dire comme autrefois la
bonne aventure dans l'espoir de se
découvrir elles aussi un destin
hors-série
[Musique]
et la jeunesse de l'impératrice continue
de servir de thèmes à une naïve chanson
de geste
[Musique]
devant les palaces qui poussent au bord
de la mer des Caraïbes on retrouve
toujours les élégantes fidèles au
costume ancestral
fidèle au Madras noué sur la tête en un
couvre-chef étonnant
[Musique]
fidèle aussi à la robe en satin broché
aux couleurs très voyantes relevées sur
les côtés pour laisser voir le jupon de
dentelle immaculée
[Musique]
fidèle enfin à la beauté métisse l'un
des charmes des Antilles français
[Musique]
la réception à l'Elysée par le général
de Gaulle des délégués à la conférence
de l'otar l'Alliance occidentale en Asie
a souligné l'harmonie des relations de
la France et des pays anglo-saxons
[Musique]
la présence commune à l'autun à la
réunion hebdomadaire du Conseil
permanent de Messieurs dinrusk Couve de
Murville et Lord yum a mis en évidence
l'importance des problèmes qui ont été
évoqués au cours des trois journées
diplomatiques dans Paris a été le
théâtre
[Musique]
à Buenos Aires le calme règne après leur
âge leur âge c'est-à-dire la révolte
militaire manquée qui durant deux jours
à plonger l'Argentine dans le désordre
la rébellion avait été déclenchée par
des forces de la marine dont les chefs
espérait ainsi empêcher les prochaines
élections et avec elle un éventuel
succès péroniste les troupes fidèles au
président de la République Roger Maria
Guido était parvenu au prix de combat de
rue relativement violent à s'assurer le
contrôle de la capitale
[Musique]
mais en d'autres points à magdalenya
notamment la lutte avait été beaucoup
plus indécise
malgré l'intervention des avions
rebelles les soldats loyalistes
enlevaient pendant la décision
quant à la base navale de Pinto Indio
aux mains des rebelles elle fut le
théâtre de combat furieux lorsque les
forces gouvernementales par 20 à y
pénétrer l'état des lieux en disait long
sur la bataille
[Musique]
de nouvelles plaies à penser pour
l'Argentine
lancez voici moi de deux ans le très
cher premier des sous-marins d'assaut
américain a propulsion nucléaire était
considéré comme saint rival quant à la
vitesse et au rayon de plongée deux
bâtiments du même type ont été
construits on doit en construire encore
19 la disparition du très cher par 2500
mètres de fond avec 129 hommes
constituent la plus grande catastrophe
sous-marine connue à ce jour
[Musique]
la circulation parisienne est sans doute
une rue d'école pour les apprentis
conducteurs on ne peut se pendant pas
dire qu'elle favorise beaucoup leur
tranquillité d'esprit face aux problèmes
épineux du changement de vitesse et au
milieu des appréciations généralement
peu flatteuses des automobilistes
confirmés
[Musique]
aussi convient-il d'apprécier
l'initiative qui a abouti à la création
en seine-et-waz d'un circuit spécial où
les candidats à la maîtrise du volant
pourront désormais évoluer entre eux et
dans les conditions même de la
circulation normale
aussitôt a pris les premiers rudiments
l'élève est lâchée seule dans sa voiture
sous la surveillance discrète cependant
du moniteur prêt à intervenir en cas de
faute grave
[Musique]
progressivement on finira par faire du
débutant plus qu'un honnête conducteur
un véritable pilote
et capable de circuler en virtuose et en
triple film coincé entre deux voitures
dans les rues de Paris à 7 heures du
soir
[Musique]
c'est un sport qui fait fureur sur les
pentes du parc national de Vannes au
Canada une paire de ski un club de golf
une balle et un parcours de 9 trous
voilà le squale le ski gold
il requiert d'une part une technique
éprouvée dans l'une et l'autre de ses
disciplines et d'autres parts un profond
mépris du ridicule
à vrai dire les règles de cet arrêt
brides semblent assez libéral on peut
craindre d'autres mariages de des
raisons au sein de la grande famille des
Sports à quand le rugby en kayak ou la
lutte bretonne à bicyclette
[Musique]
le motocross est demeurer fidèle en
Europe à ces audacées on l'a bien vu en
Espagne où il a mis aux prises des
machines de 250 cm3
parcours tourmenté à souhait douce et
fougueuses ruades et ses spectaculaires
envolés qui ne sont pas sans rappeler
les plus audacieuses des charges de
cavalerie
autre lieu autre technique en URSS un
bandage clouté comme une planche de
Fakir permet aux machines de tenir sur
une piste de glace ce qui autorise ces
virages incroyablement couchés qui
semblent un défi aux lois de l'équilibre
sport qui fait fureur près du cercle
polaire
sur le stade liberté à Dakar ouverture
solennelle des jeux de l'amitié en
présence du président Léopold Senghor et
de 25000 spectateurs enthousiastes
[Musique]
après Tananarive et Abidjan la troisième
édition des Jeux réunit les délégations
des pays et territoires francophones du
monde entier auxquels se sont joints
cette année plusieurs pays africains
d'expressions anglaises au total près de
3000 athlètes qui dans les stades et sur
les pistes de la capitale sénégalaise
vont lutter pacifiquement pendant 10
jours dans une confrontation amicale et
désintéressée
[Musique]
c'est l'athlète pierre William qui a
prêté le serment solennelle au nom des
participants à cette version africaine
des Olympiades
si les demeurées en Suisse le fleuve
tumultueux qu'il était jadis né des
glaces et des neiges des Alpes leur un
par contre on est plus aujourd'hui le
même qu'autrefois quand il aborde la
plaine d'Alsace dès 1928 l'homme a
entrepris du domestiquer son cours
inégal et dangereux en le doublant d'un
canal latéral
à la hauteur du barrage de Kembs le
Grand Canal d'Alsace commençait
d'assumer sa double mission rendre le
cours du Rhin à la navigation et
alimenter la centrale électrique dont
les si turbines travaillent sous 14
mètres de chute après la guerre depuis
1948 tous les trois ans une nouvelle
centrale s'est dressée sur le cours du
fleuve
Ottmarsheim près de Mulhouse
[Applaudissements]
la troisième de cette suite d'usine
neuve qui jalonne la partie française du
cours du Rhin de bal à Strasbourg
déserté au début du siècle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la centrale de foggle Green allie la
perfection technique à l'équilibre
esthétique de l'encens
le moins surprenant n'est sans doute pas
le décor intérieur conçu pour le plaisir
des yeux qui humanise la salle des
machines
à Marckolsheim la dernière née des
centrales du Rhin l'art c'est également
mis au service de la technique et de
l'efficacité
Laval les travaux se poursuivent l'usine
de Rina se construit à sec et
lorsqu'elle se rend achevées les
centrales hydroélectriques du rein
fourniront 7 milliards de kilowatts
heure par an le dixième de la production
française actuelle
en même temps le Grand Canal d'Alsace
s'achève des engins mécaniques puissants
tracent les berges de la nouvelle voie
d'eau plus large dans tout son cours que
le canal de Suez
avec son complément alsacien façonné de
la main de l'homme le vieux Rhin des
bourges romantiques pourra demain
assumer dans toute sa plénitude
s'attache ancestrale qui est d'être la
grande voie de communication économique
la grande artère internationale
indispensable aux échanges européens
[Musique]
réuni dans la capitale polonaise des
délégations venues des quatre coins du
monde ont commémoré l'un des drames les
plus poignants de la dernière guerre le
soulèvement et l'anéantissement en avril
1943 du ghetto de Varsovie dès 1940 les
chefs nazis avaient isolé à l'intérieur
d'un mur de 16 km 400
000 Juifs
dans ce quartier clos c'était condamné
toute une population à une vie
impossible 100 000 périr d'épidémie et
de famille
ce n'était pas assez
alors commencèrent ces impardonnables
qu'on voit vers les camps
d'extermination la solution finale était
en marche
[Musique]
matin 1943 les 60 000 Juifs encore au
ghetto par la seule vertu de l'espérance
se soulevait décidé à vendre cherment
leur vie ce fut l'anéantissement total
maison par maison
il y a de cela 20 ans
se recueillir à Varsovie n'ont pas
oublié
[Musique]
le général de Gaulle a entrepris son 18e
voyage à travers la province française
et il rendait visible ce jour-là à Sedan
il devait se rendre ensuite à Mézières
et à Charleville en reprenant contact
avec la foule provinciale le général de
Gaulle a été touché par la chaleur de
l'accueil que lui avait réservé les
populations
dans ces allocutions le président de la
République a rappelé les lignes
directrices qui inspirent l'action du
gouvernement stabilité politique
évolution sociale construction de
l'Europe
[Applaudissements]
ajouter qu'un armement moderne est une
nécessité pour la garantie de
l'indépendance du pays
partout la foule a manifesté son
attachement au chef de l'État par ses
acclamations
dans le ciel de Courchevel une quinzaine
de concurrents participent au premier
critérium des parachutistes skieur
après un saut en chute libre il s'agit
de se poser le plus près possible d'un
point de repère tracé dans la neige à
plus de 2000 mètres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en dépit de l'altitude la moyenne de
précision des 10 premiers sera de 5
mètres 17 ce qui est remarquable le
vainqueur Claude trèfle pose les pieds à
50 cm du coin idéal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette épreuve de précision au bout des
suspentes se doublent à l'arrivée d'un
concours de descente ski au pied car
c'est parachutistes sont également des
skieurs confirmés un jeu certes mais
aussi une expérience grâce à la rapidité
de leur intervention et à la précision
de leur saut ce sont des perspectives
insoupçonnées ouvertes au secours en
haute montagne par ses futurs
Saint-Bernard du ciel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas d'émotion en cours d'ennemis final
de la Coupe de France de football la
logique est respectée au grand désespoir
des amateurs de sensations fortes
à Marseille la belle aventure des
Toulonnais maillot clair c'est terminé
par un échec devant les Lyonnais échec
sévère par trois buts qui doit beaucoup
à la malchance
au Parc des Princes devant Monaco
l'équipe numéro un du football français
les Rémoises noires eux aussi ont
invoqué la malchance mais à tort ils
sont tombés sur plus fort que
race pourtant marque le premier but par
hackésby
alors commence le match poursuite Monaco
et gallize Reims reprend l'avantage
Monaco égalise encore voilà qui est fait
c'est finalement Monaco qui a le dernier
mot trois à deux Monaco et Lyon joueront
la finale de la Coupe de France
[Musique]
on l'appelle entre initier le Père
Tranquille du rock le Tino Rossi du
rythme dans sa gentilhommière de
Chevreuse Richard Anthony qui avait déjà
vendu l'an dernier 3 millions de disques
et l'un de ceux que la fortune a comblé
à l'âge 25 ans où l'on est généralement
riche que d'espérance
comment il suffit de le suivre un soir à
Paris ou à Bordeaux à Courbevoie ou à la
salle des fêtes de Melun pour comprendre
[Musique]
à Strasbourg 5 millions de ceux qui ont
entre 13 et 19 ans ont ainsi adopté des
vedettes bien à eux apôtre de leur
musique le rock et le twist
[Applaudissements]
idole nouvelle les vedettes de cinéma
n'ont qu'à bien se tenir
ce que l'exemple des Johny des Richard
ou des Sylvie dont la réussite est
inscrite dans les microscillants ne
manque pas de provoquer les mululations
témoin les vendredis du Golf Drouot ce
temple ce saint des saints du twist
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le vendredi c'est le jour où l'on vient
présenter à ses pères la petite
formation qu'on a monté entre copains
avec l'espoir de faire à son tour indice
à plusieurs l'audace c'est plus facile
[Musique]
on compte aujourd'hui 3000 formations de
ce type en France combien demain
[Musique]
fait significatif le commerce des
guitares est en plein essor on en a
vendu en un an autant qu'il s'est vendu
de voiture la guitare entendait celle
qui fait du bruit la guitare électrique
[Musique]
et on l'a choisi comme sa cravate devant
une glace
[Musique]
après quoi on cherche des partenaires il
existe pour cela tout un système
d'affichage sans oublier les petites
annonces dans les revues spécialisées
qui permettent de pressentir le
guitariste blond et le batteur châtain
de ses rêves
on s'entraîne et si l'on a de la chance
on trouve un studio d'enregistrement
dans le 16e à Paris par exemple
[Musique]
sinon avec les moyens du bord on
enregistre quand même sur place à
l'atelier ou au garage
[Musique]
être apprécié par ses copains c'est bien
mais évidemment l'important le but est
d'enregistrer au moins une bande
magnétique que l'on pourra toujours
envoyer par la poste à une maison
d'édition car ainsi vont les choses
aujourd'hui quand quelques semaines une
vedette fenêtre par la grâce du micro
sillon
[Musique]